je parle aux adeptes déglinguettes ou
bien des garden party vous serez ravis
d'apprendre que le domaine de Dampierre
vous ouvre ses portes pour de multiples
animations cet été et pour en parler
avec nous Pascal tevard le directeur
général du domaine de Dampierre et donc
ces animations ça commence dès demain
soir avec la soirée guinguette qui aura
lieu à partir de 19h 19h exactement à
partir de m'asseoir c'est lancement de
notre de notre été à Dampierre on
commence par une guinguette et on y en
aura une deuxième le 20 juillet donc des
guinguettes d'ailleurs demain soir c'est
déjà complet on espère que le temps sera
bien présent avec nous aussi et des
guinguettes qui permettent ce que je
disais tout à l'heure par exemple avec
l'expérience opéra à Saint-Quentin c'est
l'ouverture à la cultura tous par tous
les moyens c'est on offre une guinguette
on est installé devant le château à
l'ombre des marronniers et on écoute de
la musique en mangeant une planche ou en
buvant un verre et on a le château face
à nous et c'est un moyen d'appréhender
autrement le patrimoine il n'y a pas de
discours il y a pas de conférence mais
au moins voilà un moyen de s'approprier
donc là il y a les guinguettes et à
partir de du mois de juillet donc une
deuxième guinguette qui est
pré-programmée également donc là il y a
plus de place pour demain soir mais pour
le 20 juillet il y a encore de la place
pour l'instant les gens n'ont pas encore
commencé à réserver mais ça va vite se
remplir et donc on peut réserver sur
notre site internet sur le site internet
du domaine de Dampierre sur la
billetterie voilà pas de souci alors le
programme sera le même ah non non non
tout autre programme alors demain c'est
un DJ qui sera plus sur les musiques
années 80 mais vraiment en musique
d'ambiance c'est vraiment mes moments
d'échange et de convivialité un after
work si je puis dire qui se déroule donc
de 18h de 19h pardon à 22h et puis dans
les années pour le 20 juillet on est
plus on remonte un peu le temps plus les
années 70
et alors autre animation de prévu cet
été c'est la Garden Party qui aura lieu
elle tout du long du mois de juillet du
1er 30 juillet et alors là vous faites
place à l'art contemporain alors
contemporain parce que Dampierre c'est
un lieu de culture c'est un lieu de
d'accueil de l'art historiquement ça a
toujours été enfin il y a le primatisme
qui est passé par Dampierre Salviati
évidemment les grands architectes gèrent
dans Mansart le nôtre et compagnie mais
il y a aussi des grands artistes au 19e
siècle c'était vraiment un centre de
création et donc aujourd'hui pour la
première édition de cette garden party
on accueille à partir de samedi prochain
et bien des sculpteurs ou des artistes
contemporains des artistes plasticiens
dans les jardins c'est un partenariat
qu'on a mené avec des acteurs communaux
de la Vallée de Chevreuse et nous on
regroupe l'ensemble de ces artistes pour
présenter dans les jardins à l'anglaise
et bien c'est installations de ces
artistes
parce que l'art contemporain doit faire
partie
deuxième partie qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qui vous tente le plus proposer des
activités on n'a pas tous encore la
chance de pouvoir partir en vacances
avoir des activités sur le territoire
sans avoir aller devoir aller sur Paris
voilà je pense que c'est très
intéressant et puis je vais faire une
petite pub pour Guyancourt alors c'est
notre vie VTT aussi à partir du 1er
juillet donc le weekend prochain le 10
juillet ça sera un gros événement alors
c'est moins prestigieux que que votre
château mais dans le parc de l'Ermitage
on est aussi sur sur deux jours avec un
des animations DJ des food truck c'est
une présentation
de Dampierre on a des sorties scolaires
qui vont qui profitent voilà on est dans
le proximité on a une chance d'avoir un
département avec une offre culturelle
assez riche et on sait que nos écoles
aiment bien la berger la bergerie
d'angouiller le château de Dampierre
tout ça donc oui oui c'est des lieux qui
sont fortement appréciés et très
appréciées
ou pas
classique le week-end de pas qui vient
mais auquel suivant le 6 et 7 juillet on
a alors là c'est la reconstitution de la
venue de Louis XV les plaisirs de
Dampierre alors là c'est quelque chose
de très costumé très cadré parce que la
course se déplace et la cour il y a des
codes et donc deux jours pendant le
weekend où là on évolue parmi la cour et
on observe on regarde et en participe
voilà activement aussi d'une journée de
visite de Louis XV euh la visite de
Louis XV à Dampierre évidemment elle
était parfaitement décrite parce que le
propriétaire de l'époque le duc de lui
n'était le mémorialiste de Louis XV donc
pendant 30 années le duc de Luynes a
décrit la vie de Louis XV
quotidiennement évidemment quand il
invite chez lui et que le roi vient avec
Madame de Pompadour et bien il le décrit
tout ce qui s'est passé et donc ces deux
jours on réinterprète on
réédite cette visite alors c'est on l'a
déjà fait l'année dernière c'est c'est
un classique mais on évolue tous les ans
là il va y avoir un spectacle d'escrime
il va y avoir de la musique de la danse
il va avoir une taverne il va avoir un
marché de village on essaye de trouver
tous les les petites subtilités qu'il y
avait autour de cette visite puisque
c'était pas seulement une visite de
convivialité mais c'était aussi une
visite de stratégie pour le le roi comme
pour le duc et donc le public est aussi
amené à participer à l'action
il y a des ateliers coiffure il y a des
ateliers comment couture enfin voilà il
y a plein d'ateliers qui rittent cette
promenade toute la journée tous ces deux
journées pardon et bien merci beaucoup
Pascal Thévard d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en plateau alors les plaisirs
de Dampierre c'est le weekend du 8 et du
9 juillet le samedi de 14h30 à 17h30 et
le dimanche de 11h à 17h30 vous
retrouverez toutes les informations
pratiques sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran